what's the name of this topic series and
sequences very very much what's the
difference in a sequence in a series do
we know yet so here's the way I think
about it Shh there are three
interconnected ideas here one of them we
actually haven't dealt with since like
term one I want to say and that's a set
what's a set I don't think about this
for a while a sets a and this is
interesting
I'm I'm going to make a parallel
comparison with a sequence but I'm also
going to distinguish them so what's in
common between a set in the sequence is
you've got a bunch of things a
collection of object as it were right
but I think we would agree that the set
the set as Chinese Chan Bobby
Salina is the same as the set Shane
Bobby ishani showing that's the same set
of objects right of people but a
sequence as the name suggests takes a
set and it imposes on it something
special ABC is not the same sequence as
CBA right does that make sense the order
suddenly matters right so a sequence
automatic on a series is what we're
really having looking at today so
slightly a trick question so what
happens when you take a sequence and
then you add up all of the terms hence
the title you can see today you can
write it down now if you like but I
mostly just want to show you what's
going to go on here okay
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you an arithmetic progression by
the way progression is just a general
term for both a sequence or a series
doesn't tell you what you're doing with
them are you listening are you adding up
doesn't matter when you take an
arithmetic progression like this one I
know that it's sufficiently simple that
we could just go and do this by hand
like you just add up 1 plus 3 is 4 plus
5 is 9 and then all on your own right I
know you could do that but what I want
to do is try and analyze this for deeper
structure I want to see if we can
understand this better so that when you
do get a sequence or a series that's
like gross and messy you can't just do
in your head can we come up with a more
systematic and simple way to do it so
here's one window like I said before I
want to do this very visually do
you agree that this is a way to
represent 1 + 3 + 5 4 7 etc are you
happy with that okay so what I want to
do is have a little bit of a play with
this visual representation okay now for
starters this is what we've got 1 all
the odd numbers from 1 through to 11
okay now what I'm going to do next is
going to look like it makes things worse
but it actually takes advantage of a
feature than an arithmetic progression
has here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
make another copy of this arithmetic
progression so I don't have 1 plus 3
plus all the way to 11
I've got double bad are you okay with
that so far okay and we still don't know
what that's equal to but that's okay now
let me just whine back for a second to
explain why I might do this what is it
that makes an arithmetic progression
like this what makes this an arithmetic
progression as compared to say for
example 1 plus 3 plus 5 plus 8 that is
not an arithmetic rotation what does
this have that that doesn't know if it's
got a consistent pattern
it's Thank You Tyler it's it's
consistent in what way how can you
describe that pattern it's got a common
difference thank you that's that's the
key right what we're looking for is from
here to here is to from here to here is
to I'd like the next thing to also be
the same difference right and that's
what we have here now because we've got
a common difference between each one
this gap here this gap here this gap
here this gap here etc do you notice
it's the same going forwards as going
backwards like the difference is the
same going backwards so watch really
carefully because I've got two copies of
this now I can rearrange them in a way
that's more helpful namely like this
now why is this a more helpful way to
think about it right well number one
because it's arithmetic how it grows is
the same as how it shrinks I'm just
looking at from two different
perspectives yeah but secondly the
reason why this is so vastly superior is
because I've got a rectangular array and
we can work out the total size of this
really really quickly okay before we do
that I just want to highlight each of
these columns that I've got they're the
same height I could describe that height
in a bunch of different ways but again
look carefully the change is subtle a
way that if it could be helpful is that
each of these columns is the same as the
first column in the first column of
course is made up of the first in the
last term jammed together does that make
sense
so if we consider them all as the same
column you can see I've got six slots
six columns each of which is the first
plus the last term you with me so far
okay so far so good
so now that I've done the visual I now
want to think about this this is what's
going to help me okay so when we think
about this this is the part that I want
actually is not much work that needs to
be done what operation do I need to
conduct on both sides that gives me just
the original arithmetic series what do I
do to both sides let's get this hold
that thought
get a stinker are you looking for
didya lunchtime he remembers thank you
anyone else yeah that's fine
83 83 you know that you drill okay
I hit pause on you can you tell me
what's the thing I do both sides I / -
right I can't now this is what I want
but now that I've got this this is the
real key okay this is just for a
particular progression that you could
have just added up by hand okay but now
that I have this way of understanding it
right I can do this for any arithmetic
progression you ever hand me I just need
to know how many columns will you get
what are the first and last term's
and then why am i divided by 2 again
because I duplicate it in order to do
this like geometric trick right so in
other words to summarize if I've got any
arithmetic series start at some term
right I'm by the way I'm using a formula
that's been used many many times
well you recall the first term a
wouldn't you call the last term's eared
it's a no of course not because we want
to make it really confusing l for last
term ok and if you've got n terms along
the way then what have I got here right
and this is worth writing down
underneath your heading you've got n
because this is how many columns you've
got right that's how many cons you got
each column consists of the same thing
it's the first and the last term just
kind of join together and then you
divide by 2 why because we duplicated
this whole series in order to do that
geometric trick in the first place okay